Rivals raced against time to gain rights
to Tetris in the 2023 film but not
everything in the film was fact car
chases licensing lawsuits and kgb's
involvement it all sounds dramatized but
was it really here's the fact from
fiction to how the blocks really fell
in Tetris viewers are told that Russian
programmer Alexi pashitnov played by
Nikita afriamov invented the game On A
Primitive computer but there is much
more to the man and how he made one of
the most popular video games of all time
in the film project nov is working in
part for the trade Bureau e-lorg but in
actuality he was employed by the Russian
Academy of Sciences a think tank of
scientists writers and philosophers who
were often given far more freedom than
most in the mid-1980s pajanova was
working on early efforts into developing
artificial intelligence he had a passion
for computer game design and often used
the availability of new hardware to
dabble in programming his own puzzles
when it came to the original game of
Tetris Alexi pajednov was heavily
inspired by a game from his youth col
pentimenos a generic block game in which
players rearrange different shapes
constructed out of five squares to make
a solid rectangle one look at the game
and it's hard not to recognize it as the
inspiration for Budget novice digital
Masterpiece pajanov's first attempt was
essentially a computer translation of
pentamentos but he soon landed on the
idea of falling game pieces that could
be rotated when he added the feature of
completed Rose disappearing Tetris was
truly born why can't both lines
disappear at once instead of one at a
time
because
I never thought of that when Tetris came
to the Nintendo and Game Boy in the
1980s it became an instant classic but
these ports certainly weren't the first
time anyone played the game outside of
the Soviet Union while the film largely
passes that part of the game's history
the real arrival of Tetris in the west
is fascinating as it's repeatedly
mentioned in the film the rights to the
game on computers had been acquired by
Robert Stein and licensed to mirosoft a
key video game publisher in the United
Kingdom throughout the 1980s they
successfully launched the game in the UK
for computers but they weren't its only
manufacturer this is something the movie
never mentions in fact Tetris wound up
being successfully released in the
United States by mirosoft subsidiary
Spectrum halobite selling more than a
hundred thousand copies to market the
game Spectrum holiday decided to embrace
the game's Russian Roots using box art
with Cyrillic texts and images of the
iconic Saint Basil's Cathedral in Moscow
anti-seed Western Gamers with a small
Peak behind the Iron Curtain
the film opens with Hank Rogers played
by Taryn Edgerton attending an
Electronics Expo and trade show
unsuccessfully Hawking his video game
version of the classic Chinese board
game go while there his hired helper is
distracted by a booth showing off Tetris
which lures him over to reluctantly try
it while it is true that Rogers
developed a title for Nintendo based on
go what the movie doesn't say is that at
the time Rogers primarily made his
living by looking for titles to import
to Japan discovering Tetris was exactly
why he went to those trade shows in the
first place marisoft control All rights
on all platforms worldwide
Japan available Rogers claimed that he
spotted Tetris in the 1988 Winter
Consumer Electronics Show in Las Vegas
where Spectrum hollabyte was showing off
their Russian puzzle game he would
explain years later Tetris was probably
the quietest game at the show this game
was a totally different thing I wanted
to play it because it struck some basic
chord I couldn't stop playing allegedly
Rogers was so entranced by the game he
got back in line to play it over and
over convinced that Tetris was precisely
with the Japanese Market was craving
Apple TV's Tetris is a dramatic
reenactment of Hank Rogers trip to the
Soviet Union and his negotiations for
the Japanese rights to the titular video
game it's revealed that the film's
climax at Sofia the better about Sasha
who Rogers randomly picked out of a
crowd to service translator is actually
an undercover KGB operative this reveal
is meant to throw the audience for a
loop but it might surprise viewers to
learn that in reality Roger's Russian
interpreter did turn out to be a KGB
agent however unlike in the film it was
no secret when the real Hank Rogers took
his trip to Russia the woman he hired
was named Ola as Rogers wrote in an
editorial for the guardian in 2014 he
did bicker from a group of people in the
lobby of his hotel though the major
difference between the movie and history
was that Rogers was very much in the
know that he was surrounded by agents of
the state they were all KGB Corolla was
beautiful and very perky when everybody
else was Doom and Gloom just as in the
film Ola took Rogers to elor but
according to Rogers olar refused to
enter the building with him and her part
in his negotiations ended there the
film's notion that she worked with
e-lord to intimidate him or was involved
in a Sinister government plot was
totally fabricated
set mostly in 1988 the tetris film sees
Hank Rogers attempting to secure the
rights to produce the game for the
Nintendo Entertainment System in Japan
however he is told early on by
Nintendo's CEO to visit their subsidiary
in Seattle Washington when there he
discovers their American team working on
a prototype for the Game Boy company
lawyer Howard Lincoln played by Ben
miles tells him they're planning on
releasing it with a handheld version of
their biggest franchise Super Mario Land
believing that it'll help sell the new
system to a broader audience Roger
suggests that the Game Boy be packaged
with Tetris instead they are instantly
receptive and the company's lack of the
handheld rights to the title kicks off
the plot which sends Rogers to Russia
while these broad Strokes remain true
but the movie fails to mention is that
Nintendo always hope to launch the
gameplay with Tetris it wasn't Roger's
ID at all industry giant Nintendo were
about to launch a handheld game playing
device and wants to sell Tetris as part
of the package in the 2004 documentary
Tetris From Russia with Love It was
claimed that Lincoln already had a
pre-loaded version of the game on the
Game Boy when the device was first
Shonda Rogers it was then that the
Intrepid licenser knew he had to get
them the rights they needed to make it a
reality in the film after seeing the
promise of the upcoming Game Boy Rogers
flies to England to secure handheld
rights to Tetris from mirosoft when he
arrives mirasoff's license intermediary
Robert Stein played by Toby Jones is
also there when Rogers approaches the
topic of handheld rights Stein and the
Maxwell's demeanors suggest to Rogers
that nobody actually owned the handheld
rights outside of the Soviet Union
Rogers does offer to pay twenty five
thousand dollars to Stein for worldwide
handheld rights but after it's leaked in
the next scene that Stein turned around
to sell handheld rights to Atari Roger
Zen flies to Moscow to get them for
himself however the truth isn't quite as
dramatic as revealed in Tetris From
Russia with Love Rogers actually
approached Stein asking for the deal
maker to go to Moscow to help him secure
the handheld rights the tetris Stein was
often negotiating on behalf of multiple
clients so this wasn't out of the
ordinary Rogers became nervous he said
he was going to go to Russia and he kept
on saying that and he wasn't going so
I became really suspicious the truth was
that Stein was working on handheld
rights for mirasoft prompting Rogers to
hop on a plane to secure the rights on
his own
and one pivotal scene in the film Rogers
helps Nikolai bellikov the company
director of e-lorg understand how
mirasoft was able to acquire video game
rights to the game without realizing it
he points out that computers were never
explicitly defined and gives him advice
on how to ensure the mistake doesn't
happen again but according to the
real-life Hank Rogers his involvement in
restructuring contracts rebelikov and
e-lord was more far-reaching than simply
helping him to find computers to get
what he was looking for Rogers knew he
had to be open and helpful and part of
that openness meant drafting a contract
that was favorable to both sides with
Rogers issuing typical hard selling
negotiations the Russians eventually
granted him Consul rights he told the
guardian in 2014 I gave them the best
contract I've ever seen in the industry
clear concise no partly because
there wasn't time for any renegotiations
Not only was the new contract helpful to
Rogers getting the rights he needed it
was also helpful to balakov and idorg
with Rogers claiming e-lord used the
tetris negotiations as a template for
all their other deals but this didn't
sit well with the Maxwells who as shown
in the film often use the Soviet is
negotiating inexperience with
capitalists to their advantage some of
the most intense moments in the film of
all belakov's attempts to outweigh his
three Western Rivals Robert Stein Hank
Rogers and Kevin Maxwell who are all in
Moscow competing to get console and
handheld rights melakov repeatedly pits
the three parties against each other
keeping them separated and using
information from them to squeeze out a
better deal while this is partly true
the movie portrays belakov as a largely
naive official who hasn't a clue who
Hank Rogers is or what he wants in truth
bellikov was alerted to his arrival by
government agents you don't walk into a
place like that Uninvited you have to
have an invitation and then your
invitation has to be cleared with the
kgv similarly the movie includes a
corrupt KGB agent played by Igor
grabuzov who blackmails the Maxwells and
forces bellikov to sign the rights away
to mirosoft this kickstarts a
complicated scheme where pageant novel
sends it covert packs to Rogers to help
him steal back the rights the real-life
negotiations weren't quite as dramatic
while it is true that the Maxwell's
tried to exert pressure on belakov by
calling in favors from Mikhail Gorbachev
the general secretary of the USSR in
reality there was no nefarious KGB
blackmail scheme ilikov favored Rogers
because of the man's honesty Alexa Paget
knob also played a much larger role in
negotiations than the movie suggests
pushing belikov to give Rogers the
rights
in the film Rogers first visits Nintendo
in Japan to sell them on Tetris meeting
with CEO Hiroshi Yamauchi played by Togo
igawa after a quick negotiation he
agrees to Rogers producing Tetris as an
official Nintendo licensee but that
doesn't quite tell the whole story it
may surprise longtime video game fans to
learn that Legendary game designer
shiguru Miyamoto creator of Mario The
Legend of Zelda and Donkey Kong actually
had a small part to play in the story of
Tetris as detailed in Norman Caruso's
online documentary The Story of Tetris
Yamauchi was less enthusiastic than how
he was portrayed in the movie he did
have a passing interest in the game but
wanted a second opinion he turned to
Miyamoto the company's biggest creative
Force at the time who gave his boss a
thumbs up on Tetris when asked why it
was worth bringing to Nintendo he said
plainly because her secretaries and
accountants are playing it the biggest
players in Tetris aren't Gamers but
video game Publishers this includes
Atari Nintendo's biggest rival at the
time their involvement in the film keeps
them largely in the background as a
looming threats when reality was a
little more complex wait you're telling
me Atari doesn't have Tetris in America
I'm telling you Atari doesn't have
Tetris anywhere according to the story
of Tetris while Atari snagged the rights
to consoles and arcade versions of
Tetris for Japan they were far more
interested in making the game in the U.S
than in the east in fact Hank Rogers
actually secured his deal for the
Japanese territory before the mess with
the Russians muddied the waters but in
the aftermath of the events of the film
with Rogers and Nintendo winding up with
console rights Nintendo immediately sent
the cease and desist letter to Atari and
Atari responded by suing Nintendo to
settle the dispute he Lord director
Nicolai bellikov actually came to the
United States and testified in the court
case the Judgment was Swift and suddenly
Atari found themselves without rights to
Tetris and they were forced to pull
thousands of copies from store shelves
to this day the Atari version remains a
valuable collector's item those who have
seen the 2023 Tetris movie can probably
agree that some of the most exciting
moments are in the film's climax after
Rogers brings two Nintendo Executives
with him to Moscow he convinces better
call to go against KGB orders to do a
deal with mirosol Brandy and Rogers and
Nintendo the rights they were after with
a signed contract in hand the trio
rushed to get out of the country before
corrupt government operatives can get to
them this leads to a nail-biting car
chase through moscow's crowded streets
which concludes with a put Chase through
an airport it probably won't shock you
to learn that much of this was invented
for the movie truthfully while Rogers
did return to Moscow after belakov
received pressure to sign the rights to
the Maxwells it wasn't nearly as ominous
since there was no KGB blackmail scheme
they weren't trying to have Rogers
arrested also while the film claims
Rogers brings along the Nintendo
Executives because he needs their Deep
Pockets sign the deal it was really
because belakov requested they come
along he needed help in order to
convince his contacts in the Russian
government that working with Nintendo
was simply the better deal
sure every film needs to end somewhere
and the tetris movie didn't have the
time to dramatize what ultimately
happened to the game and the people
involved but even with a handful of
real-life photographs and a few brief
updates during the credits the film
mostly glosses over what happened to
Rogers and pajanov after Tetris became a
cultural phenomenon is now a good time
for American emotion in the initial wake
of the game's success its Russian
developers saw no profits after the fall
of the Soviet Union in 1991 pajanov
moved his family to the United States
five years later he and Roger started
the tetris company which finally gave
pajanov royalties on the game and its
Associated merchandise not long
afterwards pajanov took a snap job at
Microsoft as their first in-house game
designer where he remained until 2005.
as for Rogers he branched out into other
Industries founding Blue Planet energy a
renewable energy storage company and
international moon base Alliance which
aims to create livable settlements on
the moon and Mars
no